[Music]
let's go out to Virginia and talk to the
m t what's up Matt how we
doing hey do John uh thanks for taking
my call man pretty uh pretty excited
pretty nervous oh don't be nervous I'm
excited but don't be nervous all right
so what's up dude no I'm I'm nervous
because my girlfriend's gonna listen to
this because she's the reason that uh
I'm listening to you and called you and
all right chuse your words carefully use
your words care what's up she knows
about it so I'll jump to the question
and then Circle back
um it's because of a call that you took
last week about the guy who had wanted
more communication and identified with
him a lot and you told her to run so my
question is uh am I am I that guy uh
also am I asking too much uh and if so
you know how do I make peace with uh the
relationship where our communication
styles are so different and I don't get
as much as I want and there's lots of
background yeah so you could do a
10-part series on us man you love it oh
man I appreciate your call um so hey
Kelly can you fill me in on that um I
don't we we Matt we record these
sometimes up to a month apart so I don't
remember that call um I think it was the
one who the that he's talking about is
the guy the woman called in and her if
she didn't text her boyfriend first
thing in the morning all communication
all day long and you know if if she
didn't text by nine he was mad okay okay
so moving the gold post you better run
girl that kind of one yes okay so you're
that that guy sounds like you right a
little bit we diverge um in some areas
but yeah the the feelings of being an
afterthought I mean I don't need I don't
need calls every 10 seconds or anything
crazy and I don't need detailed lists of
what she does but I do feel like there's
such a huge gap in our communication and
I have also moved the goalpost but um to
use the football analogy I moved him
closer I don't ask for 10 yards for a
touchdown I just wanted to hike the damn
ball I'll touchdown well and I feel like
every go ahead oh I said I feel like
every time I I I ask for less and less
because she says she can't give more I I
I asked for less and less and she still
says nope too much nope too much nope
too much and it's tough because it's
it's I don't want to be that guy who's
driving her away and making her want to
run but I just I love this woman with
all my heart and just want to I just
love talking to her and hearing from her
and that sort of thing so it sounds like
she's moving the goalpost back so or
she's moving the gold poost too let me
put it that way
um Let me let me try to ask the question
this way sure
um well let me let you ask your question
what's your
question so is it's if I'm asking too
much if I'm if I am being overbearing um
you know we don't we're both Divorced
with kids live a town apart and she has
her kids week on week off I've got mine
maybe a third of the time and during
those sometimes seven to 10 days that we
don't see each other I really crave that
connection at least through the
telephone because we don't get to
physically see each other much um and
that's when it really feels like I I
feel like an afterthought she even she
even said extraneous uh at one point you
know and uh it was tough I mean I used
the word first to be very fair but she's
like yeah you do feel extraneous during
those times when I've just got the kids
and I'm dealing with them and and yeah I
don't have time for you so what what
what tough yeah I mean no I don't think
that's I don't you don't sound like that
other guy at all to me now maybe you
listened and felt that way but I don't I
don't hear that at all um why when she
has her kids do y'all not see each
other um so we we used to um heck we
even we were even engaged for two weeks
a couple months ago she's got um a
daughter who's 14 who is doing the
classic I hate mom because I'm a
teenager I want to kill myself when I'm
around you sort of thing I mean that's
not really the classic seems like she's
got a lot of strug struggles but maybe
not classic but there's that there's
that angst between Mom and teenage
daughter and then it's to the point
where she was making suicidal ideations
and even cutting and it had occurred
right after our engagement because she's
like I don't want you guys to be engaged
I don't I don't I don't want a new life
um and so my girlfriend called off the
engagement um after a couple of weeks
because of that not only that there's a
ramsy Solutions connection I had a
little more dep than she realized and
she's like whoa step back you know and
I'm working we're working on that I'm on
step two but um what do you mean like
she realized you you finally came clean
about you owe a whole bunch of money in
debt right she knew about she knew about
student loans uh from law school um and
a little credit card that she knew that
my The Firm that I I'm about to leave
has been really financially tough on me
and I didn't really disclose how tough
it had been so after the engagement I
said I gave her a spreadsheet and said
here I am and she's like who that's more
than I expected um but we we worked a
plan you know to to to do it together
she's a financial Wiz she's got I mean
she's just phenomenal um and I'm
struggling and that coupled with the
daughter sort of I shouldn't going off
the deep Bend but the stress with the
daughter she's like this is too much we
need to step back so that's why I don't
get to come around that often anymore
because it seems to stress out her
daughter now her daughter's living with
her her
ex-husband um now more fulltime because
of the stress so I may be invited around
a little bit more but that hasn't
happened yet in the last month and so
it's It's just tough yeah um
man I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna give it to you straight is that
cool yeah please I think these
communication challenges and the I'm all
in but wait col let's let's take a
breather let me see the
spreadsheet all of this feels like
theater to a much bigger issue in your
relationship
together it feels like they're y'all are
not nearly as close close as you want to
be yeah and y'all are not nearly as far
apart as she would feel
safe and so what happens is it's almost
like uh two magnets that are turned the
wrong way you'll just push each other
away so hard pursuer distancer kind of
dynamic yeah it just becomes you've
heard me say it on the show you just
becomes a dance where yeah I'm starving
I can't breathe I can't breathe I can't
breathe and you're my oxygen and then
the I can't breathe I can't breathe
you're smothering
me and she's using you as as an excuse
to um she's using distance from you as
an
excuse to make herself her alarm Bells
not ring off the hook because she
probably went through a gnarly divorce
that was a mess and she has a daughter
that's chaotic that's dude you can't you
can't let you can't let a teenager
dictate your life they they that young
girl
cannot handle the power of determining
her mom's dating relationships that's
too much that's too much power to give
to a child she can't carry that weight
well you hit the nail on the head with
the terrible divorce uh her ex-husband
married the Paramore the the mistress
that caused the divorce and moved her in
right away and I and I we we suspect
that that has something to do with the
um resistance to our relationship you
know another interloper but at the same
time um
you're your financial insecurity your
professional insecurity you work in a
very very difficult job nobody calls an
attorney because they're having a great
day right so you enter into people's
pain every day of your life as um uh as
a way of being and so you've identified
her your bodies identified her as your
as a cup of water as your oxygen and
when you don't get it man you ask more
where are you why aren't you me am I
just an afterthought and it's that it's
that internal can't breathe can't
breathe can't breathe like when you're
underwater a little bit too long and
then the kid won't get off of you and
all of a sudden your body goes to full
right and it just gets to that weird
dance that that's it 100% that's that's
what it feels like it's yeah it's a
craving yeah yeah yeah and so for me
um I think the conversation has to be
way way beneath communication Style by
the way that language is so frustrating
for me not to you I'm I'm really
grateful that y'all are identifying I
communicate this way I communicate that
way it's super frustrating to me that
those type of s overly simplistic models
are placed in the world because they
give people a relational out what do I
mean by that well my love language is
touch well my love language is nice is
affirmations and we just aren't
compatible and I just want to yell from
the rooftops that's just so stupid
there's nothing empirical about any of
that all of that changes over time and
if my w if I'm in tune with my wife I
know that she likes to be hugged when
she's when she's hurting and if she's in
tune with me she knows that I like it
when she puts her hand on the back of my
neck and says hey I'm proud of you like
it we don't have to devolve into this I
don't do that kind of love language my I
do what my partner needs and vice versa
and so I if yall have different
communication Styles out of the gate
great I don't really care what does she
need and what do you need right if my
wife shifted over time that's that's the
thing it always always moves right
what's important is that every month you
say hey D I'm getting ready it's getting
super stressful at work and like just a
quick hello in the morning Absol like it
changes the whole nature of my
day would you would you love me enough
to say hello
and she'd be like yeah I got that and if
she can't do that then your relationship
has much bigger issues in it or if she
says
Hey dealing with my daughter in the
morning is so
difficult and every morning I wake up in
a panic that she's even still alive or
that there's blood on the sheets again
and like just the thought of having a
chore to do which is I got to make sure
I call him back three times can I call
you when I get to work and you'd be like
yeah absolutely babe that'd be awesome
but until yall have that level of
conversation um it's just going to be
this pingpong match of well you did this
well you didn't do this and it just
becomes theater for the deeper issues
here
yeah it sounds and by the way the
scariest thing for somebody who went
through a bad
divorce who is scanning the environment
247 365 for am I safe am I safe am I
safe is finding out that the person that
they almost went all in on didn't tell
them the full
truth yeah no I I I know that I I was
definitely wrong um that's a huge regret
yeah yeah have you have you said that in
that
way I I don't know I know I've
apologized and said I'm sorry I didn't
tell you this earlier um I think it's
deeper than that I failed
you yeah no I did as 100% ACC awesome
that's awesome and failed in my I failed
in my last marriage you know it was my
fault so it's like in what way oh I
stepped out on the marriage okay I I
wasn't I wasn't honest with my ex-wife
that I was hurting and feeling unloved
and feeling uh worthless and devalued
and I found somebody that made me feel
good for a little while and uh sure I
just don't want I don't want to make
those mistakes because like this woman
is the light of my life and and I think
when she said it before when our Highs
are high they are they're they're
they're to the moon and back because we
just you know we're both we both have
similar jobs like she's active duty
military I'm Reserve now but um you know
we've got these we have so much common
ground and just love food and I love to
cook and she loves to eat and I do too
you know I just it's so much is so good
it's intense it's I mean we both said
that we fell in love the minute we
walked into the coffee shop the first
time we met you know and that's probably
damn accurate and it's it's been
wonderful but those lows are just you
know use that analogy of like the love
tank just rins and I just you know so
let me ask you a hard question
sure you've done some dumb things I have
too we all have yeah but you've painted
me a pretty clear picture of a guy that
doesn't like himself
why I was afraid you're G to ask me that
question because I haven't come up with
the answer I've been in therapy for two
years trying to figure it out
and and I can't and it's it's hard I
mean you know I had loving parents
nuclear family uh wonderful Christian
household um great career in the Marines
for you know 25 years you know some of
it active duty and um I've accomplished
a lot became an attorney like I mean
just you know a lot of things that I'm
like this is awesome I've finally done
it all but that but that's a guy that's
been that's been running from Hill to
Hill saying oh I have peace on that Hill
and then you get to that hill and you're
like well damn it I went with me there's
peace over on that hill and then you
start running and you and dude nobody
can stop you you can do anything if you
get out of active duty military after 25
years and you go to law school with all
those kids and you get out and start
practic like no one can stop you you can
do whatever you
want but that sounds like a guy that's
running from
himself
yeah and if you if you expect any woman
to fill that or that doomed statement
that Tom Cruz like whispered across the
room like if you're waiting for somebody
to complete you dude that they're
ultimately not going to be able to carry
that
weight I'm afraid I'm afraid that's what
I'm putting on here I want her to
compliment me not complete me and I'm
afraid
I'm the only way only way that can
happen that's a beautiful sentiment the
only way that can happen is if you
recognize that your oxygen comes from
within your chest not from
her I don't like my oxygen I know but
I'm telling you as an outsider it looks
good I appreciate that so what if this
what if instead of going to a therapist
and just talking and talking and talking
and
talking what if you
begin practicing liking yourself
and that sounds so cheesy I'm going tell
you something that my counselor made me
do okay okay and it melted
me and I'm tired today and so I'm
probably GNA get choked up talking about
it so she called me out once I may I
don't know if I've talked about on the
show or not but we we've she called me
out
once and she said oh my she's an oracle
right she said oh my gosh you don't like
you and I was like yes I do like no you
don't I was like I
do and she she said say it say the words
I love this guy and I started laughing I
was like I'm not saying that and she
goes say it and she goes just say it say
it to me I love this guy you know she
made me make a fist and put it in my
chest and say I love this guy ultimately
I couldn't do it yeah it was the
strangest outof Body
Experience dude I couldn't do it and she
goes there it is she goes none of the
rest of the stuff gets better none of
the rest of the stuff
heals until you're okay with you because
if you're not okay with you everybody
feels you trying to get something from
them and some people want that but that
always ends up in an unhealthy Dynamic
other people like my daughter or your
girlfriend SL fiance sgirl their bodies
sense it and they feel like they're
going to get dragged underwater by two
big guys like us and so they bolt they
bail they back
up yeah I don't want that I want her
to yeah I I want to
love Yeah God I can't even say it yeah
so exactly so here's your homework and
I'm it's GNA be as cheat dude I expect
people listening to go is that a 200 PB
Texan talking to a former Marine telling
him to put his fist in his chest and
look in his bathroom mirror and say I
love this guy five to 10 times a day yes
that's what's happening right right
now but I want you to do it and listen
when you say it I want you to
intentionally relax and drop your
shoulders down because you can probably
Flex through it that's what you've been
doing your whole life you Flex through
law school you Flex through basic you
Flex through all your promotions you
Flex through all of it that's what you
could
do but you can't Flex through making
some woman feel safe especially someone
who's already just been burned burn to
Ash that has to come from the inside out
the only way that happens is if you
admit I got to practice like being okay
with
me I can't expect somebody to carry
that I'm just going to tell you on this
side of
it it's healed my relationship with my
daughter it's healed my relationship
with my son it's healed my relationship
with my wife it's made me a general
better person to be around a safer
person to be around because I'm not
grabbing every person in my life and
saying Hold Me Up Hold Me Up Hold Me Up
Hold Me Up Hold Me Up hold me up I'm
able to walk into a room safe whole on
my own two feet and look around and say
how can I love each and every one of you
and hey here's what I need to be loved
guys I'm going put that out there that's
a totally different Dynamic so starting
today you to put your chest in your hand
and look in the mirror and say the words
I love this guy and I want you to do
that that every day for the next 30
days and then tell your wife or tell
your fiance maybe your wife one day
girlfriend I've been expecting you to
hold me up and I'm
sorry and whenever somebody can't hold
me up I get nervous and then I get
clingy and then I go looking for I start
hiding things I I keep secrets no more
no
more no
more hang on the line brother I'm going
to send you a copy of building a non-
anxious life as my gift to you read that
dude and he'll give you a road
map from point A to point B I'm start
living into these things as I
practice learning to be okay with
myself and it's good to go to counseling
dude go talk to somebody let's just
start stop the loop the loop the loop
let's start really honing in I love this
guy this guy's safe this guy can do hard
stuff this guy can take care of people
and this guy's okay saying what he needs
out loud
do you love me
too and then dude we'll deal with the
we'll deal with the communication stuff
on the back end but let's start at the
route I'm proud of you brother proud of
you and tell the truth Matt tell the
truth